aloha welcome
thanks for joining us we are
still in costa rica at continuo masaro's
shift into permanent alignment retreat
we are now
sitting down with who ended up becoming
my roommate
during the retreat we have riley god
play joining us
hi atlas i am glad to be on your show
thank you for
choosing to interview me and i'm excited
to talk about what we choose to discuss
yes love the focus on choice right off
the bat
yeah riley
also ended up writing and publishing
a book the book of riley
and he ended up
making it very simplistic
visual he's a really good writer
and this is available we'll put the link
in the bio below
for everybody yes uh and i say that
presently the kindle versions available
and the for print version will be
available soon yes yes
he gifted one to pentino that's right as
well yes because bentino played an
instrumental role in riley's
recognizing of himself as the creator as
the creator
yes that's true bentino massaro did do
just what you said
he played an instrumental role role in
um
assisting me recognize
myself and myself
i love it so
myself and myself yeah let's let's let's
play from this from a really
am the creator perspective because both
of us have awakened
to this as our true nature but it took
us
quite a bit of time to remember yeah
so let's go ahead and play with it from
a perspective of some of your
remembering and then the empowerment
that comes from that remembering
yeah so remembering
it began with
the earliest teaching that my mom and
dad
taught me about what mormons can have
happen
for them they believe in their religion
that if a member of that religion
is faithful and obedient to the
commandments and the doctrines
throughout all of mortality that they
will
enter a reception of divinity receiving
them
and then endowing them with full
creator power wow
when this was taught to me and it was
done so
like something like riley
when you go to heaven god will make you
like god
is and you will be able to create
planets
and your own worlds and your own
universe
and i heard this and i became
extraordinarily excited
and thought okay that's for why my life
is
i will live for that cause for that
glorious moment
throughout time
i began to
wish it be sooner and i was
taught i was living in a generation
that was uniquely fortunate
because jesus christ was going to return
and when jesus christ returned all who
were alive
wouldn't have to die to go and become
this transition
of human becoming as god
it would be done in an instant when
jesus appeared
and hopefully soon hopefully early
hopefully in my lifetime hopefully today
jesus
um and so i anticipated that with a
great exciting
excitement and enthusiasm also
and what ended up happening was a book
was released
and i write about the reception of uh
this book in the book of riley
a book called the secret was released
now atlas are you familiar with that
book yes okay cool
so i think most people who
are tuned in to this kind of content
have some referencing
of what the book the secret is and for
me
it was the first acknowledgement that i
could
will something to be done
the way that i'd like to see
prior to that moment in time or that
moment experiencing
did i only feel that i was on a
path that was set the mormon path
but the book the secret began to give me
back my power as the creator
will and choice yes will and choice
yes yes beautiful and so
i began thinking about applying the book
the secrets teaching to place the
desired
object in the past to receive it now
as if i want something so i imagine i
already have the thing
and i can tell the story of how i
received it
and i can also tell the story of how
it's with me now and i can also tell the
story of how it's been with me for many
moments
and i'm still being that moment i am it
yeah yeah
and so with that methodology to
manifestation
did i look at what i desired above all
things yes and that was deification
perfect and so
i applied the book the secret
to the teachings of the church of jesus
christ of latter-day saints the mormon
people
and began perceiving that this reception
into god's presence
already happened began perceiving
god welcomed me in and that i was indeed
celestialized
and exalted and defied
and placed upon the throne and given the
crown
and the right to rule and create by my
word
by my will that is already around our
necks which is another interesting key
we are always already free yet it
remains for us to recognize yes
which is so fascinating cool cool and
this was me
recognizing yes this was my way of
remembering
and what i did was i
transitioned something that the mormons
teach and the mormons are very effective
about teaching through
music their hymns their songs they sing
are like coding programming and
a word that has some negative
connotation about it is
indoctrinating i see that the hymns are
all these things indoctrinating
coding programming and dr masra imoto's
science that he does on water retaining
information
was also something that was coming to
the forefront of awareness during this
time
and so i began to perceive my word is
powerful
i ought to only say what i want to be
now not the hoping for it and so
the mormon hymn
back hopefully with the
solid internet connection though so um
to recap a little bit yes
if i may just briefly i really
appreciated how
riley described
a will and a choice
to the desire
in the north star position of becoming
god
the creator i love that
you in a sense create a
narrative structure of becoming that
and sharing all these different faces to
the story
and timeline of that process and then
that's what makes it
manifest yes yes yes okay
thank you that was cool i just want to
mention that part i like that part a lot
so
the mormons have a hymn called i am a
child of god in the song
the lyrics are teach me all that i must
do
to live with god someday
those lyrics if some
create in the mind of the singer
a dilemma yeah of not being one with god
already that's right
yeah i became aware of this and
so i call it spiritually incorrect yeah
for we are
always one in the one yeah with the one
as the one
yes and this was conceptually known
before it was directly experienced
yet the path that i am did give way to a
direct experiencing of oneness with all
is
and what is beyond and so
any spiritual literature or music
or anything that makes god
appear to be outside of you is
spiritually incorrect that is what i
call it spiritually incorrect
yes so
i applying the secret and the will to
manifest things now be done
begin perceiving that the belief and the
affirmation
i am god not i am a child of god i am
god was truest and so i would look in
the mirror and say it
i would do tapping exercises and say it
i would do what i could to integrate it
and what i was observant of at first
was that even though it was like a big
aha
i remember where i was i was in utah
valley university i was walking down one
of the halls
doing my thinking that i do and then
suddenly
it just clicked oh i should be saying i
am god
because then it'll manifest yeah then
it'll be certain
because mormons teach that there's the
possibility of you going to some other
kingdom
other than the purest and the highest
and i thought no that's not for me
that's so much not for me that i am only
going to forecast
my destination as the only one place i'd
like to have happen
yeah so i will embrace that i would i
received the reward
i will embrace that i am it i will
embrace that it was given me
yeah and the affirmation i am god i am
god now
is that the confident knowing that i
receive
everything that can be once one is
deified and being as that holy one
so with that happening i began to
receive teachers um and what i mean by
that
is suddenly on youtube there was videos
about alan watts
and he seemed to know that realization
also
when i discovered this there was no
religion there was no teacher there was
nobody saying it
i didn't know it anywhere i literally
figured it out myself
and then after figuring it out i started
by my perception to attract
teachers that were already in the
awareness yep yep
that's it when the student is ready the
teacher appears
yes and when the student
is has learned fully recognized
then the teacher disappears and then the
student becomes the teacher
that will be a funny future um
and um and and also with what you say
about uh the lesson it was as if
the simplicity of the lesson was learned
and so teachers could appear
to play that back and forth but what i
would say
is that um the the knowledge is had
already
for someone to arise within i
to be bearer of the knowledge i'm
already in the knowing
for someone to appear being knowing also
exactly
now this isn't to diminish or negate the
value
of reflecting because i will say that in
reflecting
with my mirror or my my appearance of
other
the one that lives in my imagination
within my mind
i am being a refining of of what i
prefer
what i like and a learning of what it is
that you like
and what you're about and so that has
been the cultivation of service and this
retreat in costa rica has obviously been
a culminating
uh point to achieve that
but the only other thing that i'd like
to say and i
include all of this in the book of riley
um and you can see this strip here that
says not for resell the the one
that will be printed will be just as
blue as the book of mormon is
in the book i had an archetypal
purification also
to become jesus i had to transcend
attachments to characters
that i esteemed to be god
including the image of jesus but also
including the images of
um well you know this is more
interesting so with the with the
pictures that are going on right here
this is when i met matt kahn and i met
him in sedona
and he was super sweet
and surprisingly
founded it was
kind of astonishing to see somebody of
his stature
be so resolute in his knowing
of what he perceives as truth
and so then these were some of the
communicators like
alan watts yes yeah that that ended up
they
came into uh of course yeah please
what ended up happening was when i
started hearing alan watts and i was
listening to him
i also started listening to um
somebody called bentino massaro perfect
okay
and bentino
was teaching yes you were god
and then there is a realization beyond
that
that you really ought to give yourself
if you are the
willpower and fortitude and um
determination to happen
and as his language began instilling
within me
i simultaneously was also having a
self-inspiration to detach from all of
my physical material
and i went through an event that
kind of catalyzed that yeah there's the
inventino together
and you have live friends here ocean
is in space yeah i am the creator's
child i'm a frequency and music
yes um
child of the creator and creator uh
i'll speak to that because of that
comment thank you
and i'll say that there was
the knowing that god
was on my side throughout my
um becoming my own philosophy becoming
my own religious thought
and i did so by um
channeled writing exercises that gave me
permission to
leave the church which was something i
had to do
to empower myself to make the choice to
go without a system
and it was necessary to do that because
it required courage and
it required courage because nobody was
doing it and it was all about family it
was
it was challenging to get out of that
pot
um but
i say all this to say that oh yes
we can also continue on that thread
where you were saying about continuous
god play
okay okay okay um
teachings were very helpful
in me
god um kind of way
it was like no this is absolutely it and
there is something that is that
and uh what ended up
happening as a result of this was i went
through and
detaching from all material possessions
and i also removed my
name from the records of the church
because i felt like it was
um like like it had somehow and i
belonged to the church of
jesus christ of latter-day saints
i know i am i know
god's plan of following
his way it goes on and on
there's so many catchy songs there and
they just roll around inside the mind
um and to extricate them and be clear
finally
as to embrace the thought that
everything that i had been
might be false yep that's a lot
of disruption of one's fundamental
actions
yes in their world that's a whole leap
of
courage that is required
to take with last work that they've
created around their understanding of
metaphysics and then just be able to
take a massive transition
that liberates them from what is more
cage-like to what is more
so this occurred
and pushed me through my worship of
external symbols
that was something that was also
transcendent
and when i did that and released
attachments to physicality
physical possessions i also was able to
give myself permission to release my
awareness of the body from the body
and created a perceived moment of um
separation uh it's it's paradoxical but
the realization of separation
is the realization of true unit you need
the netty netty
approach of negation as is taught by
siddhar mashwar and sargat
maharaj that you must negate and say i'm
not
my thoughts i'm not these perceptions
and i'm not these sensations i'm not
these
objects i'm not even my mind right i'm
not my body i'm not my name
right i am awareness
and then that is impersonal and eternal
and then i'm not even awareness
and so then that's sort of the netty
nettie approach which you have to do in
order to
recognize recognize yourself as the
creator as the source
and then you can include so you can
negate first and then exactly
exactly and that's what happened and
when it happened i was sitting on
pavement i had a friend in front of me
we were talking about what had just
uh transpired and then i suddenly felt
my body start to
get um extraordinarily
straight and
and um and that i felt like i was coming
out of the back of me
perfect um and that for a moment i
thought
aliens are abducting me
like bye bye earth like i don't know
what's happening but i think i know
what's happening but i don't know what's
happening but i think i know what's
happening but i don't know what's
happening
and as that was going on
i fell back into nowhere
and nothing perfect
and saw that life is yeah and perceived
a body living yet that it knows nothing
is available for me to be perceiving
a reality that is within one
within one light sphere within one life
that was
looking at what i was and so
um i feel like commonly it's called an i
yeah um i call it an eye totally um the
main central question of ramana maharshi
is
what is i yeah what is i
now when i came out of this um
i was calling it uh a cosmic butterfly
i was telling everyone with grand
enthusiasm
you live in the eye of a butterfly you
live in the eye of a butterfly you live
in the eye of a butterfly
that's what i perceived it was was this
cosmic angelic
butterfly and and it wasn't a form like
what human is
and human exists in it but it takes all
of humans mind
to like like try to like conjure the
thought of the one that appears to be
formless
to what the form of humanity is and i
was calling it a name but what i
became aware of was vast intelligent
space
that was being the
um like the campus for it to sit
in um and and i came all the way out to
that
knowing my come from to be that
that is indescribable
words were words to describe this were
not happening as it was happening it was
happening
i was being the happening and as i come
out i tried to explain but it was funny
in that moment coming out did i know i
cannot actually
say anything about this curiously there
are beings around me asking me like what
happened what what did you do what was
that
there was witnesses they saw
and the the come back you know you
mentioned something earlier atlas
about um
you you oh and it was it was that we we
need to go all the way out
negation yes negation um which
i would uh reword is the denial of the
appearance of all things
yeah the denial of what is transient the
denial of what is infinity
in order to be able to find what is
permanent and what is infinite
and then to abide as that right and
include then yes yes now i was only able
to do that because i was
willing to believe something beyond the
teachings
that i had received from childhood
exactly
the 3d programming right right right
right and when i came back in
it became clear to me that the one
that we call god is me
we wish that experience for every single
one of you
this entire retreat is
architecting igniting the global
awakening through all of our callings
to help you all with recognizing
yourselves
as the creators yes for they benefit
for thy excelling for the betterment of
the world that you
exist in and for those around you
we are committed to serving
our world to making it into what
is everybody helped by the effect of
existing within this dream
and so as long as it continues and we
know it's illusory
we know it's not real in this moment i
saw this world
as imaginary light
with figures in it that weren't really
me
but i pretended to be them or they
pretended to be i
and
i did not remain in this
[Music]
all right we are back with our
internet connection excellent so
resuming
again yeah we've been
hitting on the
yeah specifically we've been mentioning
medication style
to recognize oneself as the creator
and then including the creation and
making that in the ignition of the
global awakening
available very simply for
all of you that are in your true nature
yet
and also riley's journey along the way
as well because that moment that he
described a couple of minutes ago
where he
felt that true nature and it became
something that he would avoid
as that is what sachin ananda
of oneself as the creator in order to be
able to
re-melt and flow as that vibration
and otherwise the mind is
rampantly toiling us around
and we deserve that peace
and that joy and that god play
and not the suffering
yet um i completely agree with that and
i can say that the name god play
and the story of that is interesting
because it comes from an inversing
of the name that was given to me
called riley james workman isn't that
nuts that his last name birth was
workman
it's like the opposite work man to god
play
exactly exactly and
the early conceived i'm calling myself
play god
um just riley play god i was self the
comment
but then i had the realization okay now
that i am god
play exactly and so
all of the teaching of the realization
is just that
go to the height of the spiritual
platform or
edges of awareness that you can
uh if you can all of the way out it will
benefit and so teachers like bentino
massaro who offer
a very clear path
to thoughtlessness
is highly beneficial i recommend him for
that
we do and then we are excellent examples
of
what it's like to be in the awakening of
that
now being that playing that
that's what i am i am god playing
perfect perfect
and that is our true nature
and the subtlety and sensitivity that
it's required to recognize that as
one's true nature is these direct path
teachings that sort of bring people away
from infinity and from transience to
what is permanent to one's source
yes so um atlas
in our time together um
what do you feel has stood out as
uh something that perhaps you've
observed that you feel like the
audiences around the world should be
aware of also
that perpetual netty netty equals
freedom
that one was really powerful across the
retreat
and even
many of the retreat attendees that we
love
and adore tremendously are
in many ways being slightly
driven around by their egoic hitchhiker
that does not want to dissolve because
people pass a lot of time socializing
people pass a lot of time doing things
in the illusion
in maya that they're not that aware of
they're not vigilant
of right and so the abiding process
in the perpetual nettie nettie that's
what leads you
to freedom yes yeah that was a core
point cool yeah um i feel like i de uh
directly relate
to that kind of focus
and have gone through a transition of
purification recently
where i used to be a lot of mindless
conversations with beings existing
within myself
and would do so as a ritual of cannabis
smoking
where we pass around a joint and we
would just get high together and
talk about what we got to talk about um
and what i have done recently is i have
actually
let go of that practice perfect
and have discovered that i am more
available to
do what i actually care about perfect
which is not only this but there's
more of this these coming and there's a
lot of other great
projects that are catalyzing igniting
the global awakening that
that now the space has been created to
align with that rather than the
in the choice architecture going towards
that highest star
of all of these incredible igniting
global awakening projects versus this
one which is the perpetual
cannabis smoking and having vapid
mundane conversation
which is again it's where we find
comfort yeah yeah well and i will say
it was instrumental in
uh being a more relaxed body that could
have a more expanded view
and now it is not
of service for me to do it that way
there you go
and and i uh i talk about uh
much of my substance use in the book of
riley
and so i'm i'm here to say
wherever you are in that phase of
exploration good um
and do it completely be as bentino
masaro calls it a completionist
and you know finish all of your cannabis
levels
and um and and then be what you actually
want to be
and and that doesn't require uh anything
of the world
to know more than now can give you um
there's there's literally nothing that
needs to
happen for you to know exactly what you
want to be now
you i know it i know it i know it it's
here it's me
it's me being this let's play
with god play more metaphysically
what we have found to be our true nature
is that we are
eternally exploring
these realities and that
god play is a really good way to explain
that
process we have a desire to play
to get to know ourselves to undergo a
process
of forgetting and remembering or hide
and seek where
each one of us gets our own unique
escape room of conditioning that we put
ourselves into
that we then unwind the contracted
egoic separate finite entity into
the relaxed empowered
state of i am the creator
and so this is but one of our creations
this is but one of our songs
in the eternal symphony and so that is
when we say god play
if you would like to potentially come in
and join
in this segment that god play is
that how do you feel about it yeah yeah
um i'm remembering myself as a
five-year-old
that was told you could be as god is
and i experience full circle that the
five-year-old self
knew it all along was just encumbered
with a whole lot of
nonsensical teachings and coding and
programming
that was released by focus and
vigilance and so here i am now being god
playing
and example i can give of this is in
addition to
writing well what i feel is a necessary
foundation for to
pursue my future i now be by imagining
it i
have plan and vision for how to make the
next
chapters and god
playing is me in the full confidence and
knowing that is okay
for me to write what i feel is best and
to embody it and to make it real
by doing real things in this real
illusion
to enact it to cause it to spark it
to generate it to manifest it
and so i am the application of
everything magical i am aware of
to the commanding of my will be done
love that so that's a really important
component
to once you negate recognize oneself
as the infinite creator the level of
empowerment with that will
and choice and manifestation to bring
forth creative spirit
energy from a place of 100 percent
defined purity and service to others
you have an unlimited amount of options
of what exactly you
will create
and to do it from a place where you're
not
trying to extract peace and happiness
from experiences and substances and
relationships and maya the illusion the
transits affinity
but rather you recognize your major
assad
you are peace and happiness and you are
bringing that
to the world bring that to everything
you
create to your friendship your
relationships etc
yes yes yes
so i feel that encapsulates everything
i i feel for sure that uh
that's the point for sure and the whole
and
all yeah yeah we did a really solid job
on that
i want to ask you one question to write
what is most beautiful
immediately i think of what i've written
in the book riley let's do it all right
oh yeah what's most beautiful i can hold
it sure
yes is she she's most beautiful
and tell us what she embodies god
and is reflection of myself alive within
my
reality that i am living and so
she's also an extension of the world
given shape and form and conscious
awareness as human is and so
it's like i'm witnessing the face of the
planet and the will
of of the world
and to be brought face to face with that
um gives the effect of awe
i love ah
yeah her name yes
is takaya takeya
yes beautiful tikiya taka
takea is most beautiful takea
is even here beyond beautiful
like the absolute you cannot describe
what she is and yet she exists
i look upon with so much wonder and awe
for her existence
yeah which is a perfect way to
describe god play
if we don't have awe
for the very fact that we
are yes that we exist
that we are aware
that we are playing
then investigate why do i not
have awe for
the fact that i am
and in that self-inquiry process
if you put that into that star position
in the choice architecture and you
dedicate yourself
desire self-realization
you will pierce that veilus fail and
recognize yourself
as the creator fast
yeah it is
a realization without time
and you're encouraged to get there as
quickly as as quickly as you can
compound interest baby yep yeah that was
great i'm so pumped
riley's got a lot of great stuff coming
up if you want to
check out the links in the bio below we
have both
the book of riley there as well as we
have riley's instagram
go and give him a follow he's got some
great content on there you can send him
a message if you want to create together
across projects good idea and if the
video brought you value
give the video a like helps the youtube
algorithm thumbs up
thumbs up yeah share like and subscribe
click that bell button got
he's got it do the things
i love it leave us a comment below with
how you felt about the episode we would
love to
hear from you as well and yeah if you
haven't yet subscribed also share the
video with people that you know that
this would bring
positive influence to and
that is all i am
the creator
the creator i am
aloha aloha